[Musique]
vous êtes le ministre en charge du
numérique est-ce que vraiment est-ce que
vraiment les mineurs n'auront plus accès
au porno est-ce que vous allez réussir à
mettre fin à fléau écoutez il y a un an
et demi port 9 xmster tukif xnxx vidéo
les 5 sites pornographiques les plus
importants ont été assignés devant le
tribunal judiciaire de Paris pour qu'il
les bloque pourquoi parce qu'il ne
vérifie pas l'âge de leur visiteurs
alors qu'ils y sont tenus par la loi le
résultat c'est quoi c'est que 2 millions
d'enfants sont exposés chaque mois dans
notre pays à des contenus
pornographiques et des enfants parmi les
plus jeunes à 12 ans la moitié des
petits garçons dans notre pays sont
exposés chaque mois à ses contenus et
c'est révoltant c'est un scandale donc
ils ont été assignés et pour autant ça
continue aujourd'hui le tribunal va
rendre son verdict et je souhaite qu'il
soit exemplaire je vous souhaite qu'il
bloque ces cinq sites pour que désormais
et bien les sites pornographiques
vérifie l'âge de leur visiteurs pour que
nos enfants soient enfin protégés donc
ça veut dire que vous couperez tout
court c'est à dire que vraiment le site
il y aura même plus 18 ans pas 18 ans ce
sera coupé absolument il n'y aura plus
d'accès à ces sites tant qu'ils ne
mettent pas en place un système fiable
légal solides c'est la loi tant qu'il ne
vérifie pas l'âge de leur visiteurs et
s'ils peuvent être bloqués sur des
décisions du juge et dans ces cas-là ça
a un effet immédiat c'est un effet
immédiat c'est le juge qui le précisera
dans son verdict s'il décide de suivre
cette voie là mais vous savez vous
espérez vivement qu'ils suivent cette
voie là je le souhaite vivement car
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale de
santé publique je suis père de deux
enfants et je trouve ça révoltant il y a
une loi qui a été votée par le Sénat 7
semaines qui voudrait se diriger vers un
certain nombre de contrôles c'est contre
il pourrait passer par quoi le projet de
loi qui a été adopté à l'unanimité du
Sénat et que je présenterai à
l'Assemblée nationale à la rentrée
prévoit que pour l'avenir on puisse en
quelques semaines seulement ordonnée le
blocage et le des référencements des
sites pornographiques
pas devoir attendre un an et demi comme
ça a été le cas pouvoir le faire en
quelques semaines ça sera un outil de
dissuasion suffisamment puissant pour
amener tous les sites pornographiques et
pas seulement les cinq que je viens de
citer à vérifier l'âge de leur visiteurs
vous avez pas peur effectivement qui
renonce de leur cendre sous d'autres
appellations parce que comme vous le
dites il y a ces cinq-là qui sont les
cinq qui ont été assignés mais j'imagine
qu'il y a une voilà une galaxie d'autres
sites porno qui vont réussir à
contourner cette décision non c'est
précisément pourquoi on a pris cette
mesure qui permettra en quelques
semaines de faire fermer un site qui ne
vérifie pas l'âge les visiteurs et il
vérifieront comment il vérifions avec la
carte d'identité avec faudra il existe
aujourd'hui des des solutions qui sont
d'ailleurs utilisées communément sur
Internet elle passe par la carte de
paiement elle passe par une estimation
de votre âge à partir appareil photo ce
sont des solutions qui sont imparfaites
mais qui sont suffisantes
et qui éviterait l'exposition massive et
parfois involontaire de nos enfants
assez contenus qui peuvent avoir pour
eux des conséquences dramatiques sur
leur santé troubles de l'attention
troubles du sommeil trouble de
l'alimentation développement de conduite
à risque les études sont nombreuses et
ont démontré qu'il y a bien là un
scandale de santé publique ceci étant
dit nous aurons besoin de solutions
peut-être plus fiables plus protectrice
de des données personnelles que celles
qui existent aujourd'hui j'ai donc
encouragé des entreprises françaises à
se lancer dans ce domaine-là
dans le domaine de la vérification d'âge
sur Internet parce que nous en avons
besoin évidemment et c'est urgent pour
les sites pornographiques nous en aurons
besoin également pour vérifier l'âge à
l'entrée sur les réseaux sociaux et pour
l'entrée sur d'autres sites dont nous
voulons préserver nos enfants j'allais y
venir justement Jean-Noël barreau vous
qui êtes en charge du numérique après
ses émeutes le président de la
République a évoqué la possibilité je
cite de couper les réseaux sociaux
lorsque les choses s'emballent le
ministre de la Justice avait même dit on
va faire péter les comptes concrètement
c'est vraiment une option sur la table
ou c'était juste pour montrer le muscle
concrètement le président de la
République nous a demandé dès le début
des émeutes de mettre une pression
maximale sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous les avons
convoqué vendredi dernier pour les
rappeler à leurs obligations légales
retirer les contenus illicites qui leur
sont signalés et répondre aux
réquisitions aux demandes de la justice
pour le besoin des enquêtes mais nous
leur avons demandé également d'exercer
une vigilance
particulière sur les fonctionnalités de
leurs services qui concourent aux
atteintes à l'ordre public et force
cette constater puisque je les ai
convoqué une nouvelle fois mardi qu'ils
ont été réactifs ce sont des milliers de
contenus qui ont été supprimés des
centaines de comptes qui ont été
supprimés des dizaines de réquisitions
qui ont été traités ceci étant dit nous
restons particulièrement vigilants et le
président de la République a souhaité
que nous puissions analyser à froid le
rôle que les réseaux sociaux ont joué
dans cette affaire que nous puissions
évaluer si nous disposons bien de tous
les outils juridiques pour les
contraintes le cas échéant et pour que
ce que nous avons vu ne se reproduit
plus sur un bouton et nous avons donc
lancé un groupe transpartisan à parité
député sénateurs qui va travailler cet
été et qui fera des propositions qui
pourront éventuellement être prises dans
le projet de loi que je présenterai à
l'Assemblée cette idée de pouvoir couper
internet c'est légal en démocratie
les la question n'est pas de de
supprimer les réseaux sociaux ce qu'il
faut supprimer ce sont leurs défauts ce
sont leurs failles en matière de respect
de la vie privée en matière d'atteinte à
l'ordre public et c'est ce à quoi nous
travaillons juste une question vous
saviez vous que le fondateur de
télégramme vous avez obtenu la
nationalité française vous y êtes pour
quelque chose je n'y suis pour rien mais
je j'étais au courant effectivement ça
paraît bizarre quoi non il a obtenu la
nationalité française selon une
procédure assez spécifique presque
élitiste qui est procédure de l'étranger
émérite et il s'appelait Pavel Durov il
est russe et il s'est fait appeler Paul
durouve pour obtenir la nationalité
française ça vous paraissait je crois
pas qu'il se fait appeler comme ça pour
obtenir la nationalité française mais il
arrive régulièrement que des chefs
d'entreprise puissent bénéficier de
cette procédure notamment quand ils ont
rendu des services à la France
il en a sans doute rendu ce qui a lui a
permis d'obtenir
de la République parle beaucoup à ses
équipes sur sur le réseau télégramme
mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit pour
rendre service qu'il a obtenu non ça
fait ça vous paraît en tout cas les gars
normal
service là mais oui il y a des chefs
d'entreprise qui lorsqu'il répondent à
un certain nombre de conditions peuvent
bénéficier de cette procédure merci
Jean-Noël Barrault d'être venu dans ce
studio ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes le ministre en charge du numérique
et vous le dites vous espérez beaucoup
de fermeté dans la décision du tribunal
aujourd'hui qui pourrait donc décider de
fermer purement et simplement les cinq
principaux sites pornos parce qu'ils ne
savent pas parce qu'ils n'ont refusé de
véritablement vérifier que les personnes
qui s'y rendre ont plus de 18 ans merci
à vous il est 7h48 et on va parler
vacances